bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui refait la
semaine politique et parlementaire avec
à mes côtés kathia gilder bon genre
katia bonjour oriane coup d'envoi de
l'euro de football qui se déroule en
france pendant un mois une compétition
qui débute dans un climat social tendu
grève à la sncf chez air france et
conflit des éboueurs des mouvements
sociaux qui risquent de nuire au bon
déroulement de la compétition
la loi travail poursuit son parcours
législatif le texte arrive dans
l'hémicycle du sénat ce lundi 13 juin il
a été largement réécrit la commission
des affaires sociales a supprimé des
articles comme celui sur la
généralisation de la garantie jeunes et
les sénateurs veulent mettre fin aux 35
heures et toute la semaine c'est le
projet de loi sapin deux qui étaient au
menu des discussions à l'assemblée
nationale encadrement des lobbys lutte
contre la corruption protection des
lanceurs d'alerté
le texte vise à lutter contre une
finance débridée selon les mots du
ministre michel sapin et c'est une
semaine sous le regard de patrick le
hyaric bonjour bonjour vous êtes
l'invité de parlement hebdo député
européen de la gauche unitaire
européenne et directeur du journal
l'humanité actualité parlementaire
politique et sociale commencé à lundi
exactement rien dire on commence la
semaine avec un retour sur une week end
chargé pour le front de gauche
pierre laurent d'un côté jean luc
mélenchon de l'autre il prononçait tous
deux un discours dimanche pierre laurent
en clôture du congrès du parti
communiste qui s'est tenu ce week-end et
hockey dans le au cours duquel il a été
réélu secrétaire national et jean luc
mélenchon lui à l'occasion du
rassemblement de la france insoumise
retour sur ce duel à distance avec
astrid de vilaine à un an de la
présidentielle la gauche de la gauche
n'est pas encore en ordre de marche
dimanche pierre laurent et jean-luc
mélenchon ont tenu deux meetings
différents à aubervilliers
pierre laurent tout juste réélu à la
tête du parti communiste pour 2017
ils souhaitent une candidature de
rassemblement je sais l'obstacle que
constitue la multiplication potentiel
des candidatures qui risque d'empêcher
cette convergence
non il n'est pas trop tard ce n'est pas
vrai soyons conscients de nos
responsabilités
dans le public certains frondeurs du
parti socialiste ont fait le déplacement
il espère aussi réunir l'ensemble de la
gauche
et nous nous sommes ceux qui tentons de
vraiment de rassembler la gauche parce
que sans ce rassemblement il n'y aura
aucune chance de voir un candidat de
gauche au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle à quelques kilomètres de
la place stalingrad à paris
jean luc mélenchon tient son premier
meeting de campagne le candidat de 2012
assume sa candidature est bien associé
d'une élection présidentielle
il fallait commencer par régler le
problème le plus simple trouver un
candidat mais voici j'ai vous appelle à
la campagne qui n'est pas seulement
faite pour témoigner je vous appelle à
une campagne pour conquérir le pouvoir
jean luc mélenchon en appel à toutes les
bonnes volontés pour rejoindre son
mouvement et tout le monde est bienvenu
dans cette bataille
le parti de gauche revendique dix mille
participants à ce premier rassemblement
chez les militants on espère que pour la
campagne
le front de gauche sera réunifiée je
peux vous dire moi habitants le 19e que
j'ai des amis également du parti
communiste qui soutiennent également la
candidature est donc il ya je ne doute
pas en quête d'un point de vue des idées
il ya beaucoup de communistes qui
partagent nos idées qui se retrouveront
dans la campagne
créditée de 12 à 14% d'intentions de
vote
c'est sur l'opinion que jean luc
mélenchon mise pour rassembler derrière
lui les autres forces de gauche patrick
le hyaric le front de gauche peut-il
encore être réunifiée oui bien sûr
c'était un beau projet une belle idée il
faut sans doute pas continuer tel qu'il
était c'est à dire seulement un
rassemblement au sommet de quelques
partis mais peut-être l'encré plus
profondément dans la sétoise dans la
société qui deviennent une grande
affaire citoyenne et divergences ne sont
elles pas trop forte en pneus il n'y a
pas de
il y a évidemment des points de
différend sur un certain nombre de
questions tournent certain nombre
d'enjeux propre à programmatique mais le
parti communiste a déjà choisi des
candidats avec lesquels ils n'étaient
pas d'accord en tout et pour tout par
conséquent la le ce rassemblement est
possible seulement le jean luc mélenchon
même d'ores et déjà sa campagne il lui a
donné un nom la france des insoumises la
stratégie du parti communiste elle est
un petit peu différente puisque lui il
veut créer les conditions d'un
rassemblement le plus large autour d'un
nom au fus style celui de jean luc
mélenchon alors sur les terrains sont on
l'entend tiendront un peu moi surtout
philippe martinez aujourd'hui semble
beaucoup plus audible que pierre laurent
quelle étrange retournement au mail vous
savez la cgt a toujours été a toujours
été audibles dans la société la cgt l'a
beaucoup à toujours jouer des grands
rôles dans la société comme le parti
communiste mais en 36 la cgt a joué un
grand rôle à la libération elle a joué
un grand rôle
comme en 1968 et a et a' et à d'autres
périodes le que philippe martinez soit
sur le devant de la scène c'est tout à
fait normal puisque il est lui confronté
à une question de fond dans les
entreprises dans les services publics
qui est celle d'une d'une loi de
précarisation du travail
on reviendra sur / cette campagne
présidentielle et la candidature de
jean-luc mélenchon à la fin de cette
émission avec jean ferrat c'est notre
partenaire du scan du figaro alors mardi
on évoque la situation à la sncf qui
s'étaient durcies à la proche du coup
d'envoi de l'euro
le gouvernement a donc repris en main
les discussions sur l'accord
d'entreprise qui prévoit une
réorganisation du travail les grévistes
estiment que la nouvelle convention
collective a fait perdre des droits
explications avec alix échelon la
direction de la sncf et les syndicats
avaient trouvé un compromis mais il a
été refusé par sud rail fo en question
la possibilité d'accord au niveau local
pour déroger à l'encadrement du repos
donc aujourd'hui si on signe cet accord
c'est valider des années de régression
sociale et des conditions de vie et de
travail des cheminots six sud rail fo
souhaite maintenir la pression la sortie
de crise dépend essentiellement de la
cgt pas de mot d'ordre concernant la
mobilisation ce mardi la cgt cheminots a
laissé décider ces syndiqués en ag de la
reconduite ou non de la grève
sûr qu'on va reconduire
dans les ag dès le départ on l'a dit ce
qu'on veut c'est le retrait de la loi
travail et le retrait du décret socle à
la sncf et donc
le texte qui sert de colonne vertébrale
à la régression sociale qu'on veut nous
imposer chez les cheminots des points de
blocage qui subsistent mais la cgt
cheminot a pourtant elle même expliqué
que le projet avaient avancé dans le bon
sens
pas de consignes de reprise du travail
pour autant car une ombre plane celle de
la mobilisation contre la loi elle
conneries la sncf n'est pas directement
concerné par la loi travail mais le 14
juin prochain une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation nationale est prévue
continuez le bras de fer permettrait à
la cgt cheminot d'afficher sa solidarité
avec la centrale tout en confortant sa
position de leader syndical non on va
revenir sur le contenu de cet accord
mais peut-être une question sur la
situation le coup d'envoi de l'euro qui
est donné dans ce contexte là de blocage
françois hollande a promis qu'il
prendrait toutes les mesures nécessaires
face aux grèves
vous vous attendez à des réquisitions je
ne sais pas c'est une c'est une décision
du gouvernement c'est possible je pense
pas que ce soit la bonne méthode
d'une part une insuffisance de
discussion d'autre part l'utilisation du
49-3 maintenant des réquisitions la
tentative de passage en force je pense
qu'il ya d'autres méthodes possibles
notamment celle de la discussion et cc
consomme tutuelle de la gauche de de
discuter d'essayer de trouver une issue
quand on a une difficulté il faut bien
pétition soit c'est vrai qu'elle est oui
mais c'est vrai vous avez raison mais je
trouve assez curieux ceux qui se
déchaînent depuis quelques heures
comparé à ce qu'on disait des
populations et des travailleurs
brésiliens au moment de la coupe du
monde de foot
nous étions en france b à ba devant ces
travailleurs qui qui manifestaient qui
protestaient qui réclamaient que de
l'argent qu'ils avaient été mis dans les
équipements pour la coupe du monde de
foot soit mise dans la vie quotidienne
ça c'était bien mais ici ce n'est pas
bien quand nos propres salariés sont
dans l'action sur une question
fondamentale de notre part de la part
des médias en général et des pouvoirs
publics sauf que la grève à la sncf n'a
pas de rapport avec la loi travaille à
la sncf les négociations ont eu lieu des
concessions aussi est-ce que la grève a
encore un sens non il y à il y a dans
l'accord de la sncf à un rapport entre
l'article 2 de la loi travail et un
article 39 de ce qui est en discussion
d'un règlement à la sncf qui prévoit
précisément le même système d'accord
local d'accords d'entreprise et donc il
y a un lien entre tous à ceci s'ajoute
le ce qui est imposé avec ce qu'on
appelle le quatrième paquet ferroviaire
qui touchent évidemment à notre réseau
en général mais aux consignes aux
conditions de travail des salariés
puisque on va mettre les salariés de la
sncf en concurrence avec des salariés du
prêt dé voir d'entreprises étrangères et
on voit bien donc là ce qui est à
l'oeuvre ce qui est à l'oeuvre
c'est un harmonisation eu une pression
vers le bas du droit du travail par
l'ird la concurrence la sncf devra faire
face à l'ouverture du marché à la
concurrence en 2020 est ce qu'elle sera
prête sans se moderniser sans se
restructurer mais moi je ne je ne
souhaite pas qu'elle soit prête je suis
contre cette concurrence parce que nous
avons besoin d'un grand service public
ferroviaire comme nous avons besoin d'un
grand service public de l'électricité
continuer comme nous le faisons
aujourd'hui c'est tenter certes démolir
le statut des cheminots créer des
comptes des conditions plus difficiles
de travail plus de fatigue plus de
stress mais au bout du bout
de cela c'est la sécurité des voyageurs
qui sera mis en cause par conséquent moi
je ne suis pas d'accord avec la
concurrence je suis d'accord qu'on crée
les conditions que la sncf la grande
entreprise nationale
ll puisse vivre elle puis s'être
désendetté elle puisse se moderniser et
nous en avons besoin tous
il ya tellement de travail tellement de
train à réparer tellement de wagons
nouveau à mettre sur les rails que nous
en avons besoin tous alors je vous
propose d'entendre votre point de vue
sur un autre sujet la loi sapin 2 qui
était en discussion à l'assemblée
nationale doit qui vise à lutter contre
la corruption dans certaines entreprises
à moderniser la vie économique est
encore à encadrer les salaires des
patrons des entreprises et aussi à mieux
protéger les lanceurs d'alerté on en
parle justement avec stéphanie des
pierres françois hollande l'avait promis
michel sapin leur a laissé la main les
députés ont élaboré un véritable statut
pour les lanceurs d'alert désormais il y
a une définition un lanceur d' alerte
c'est la personne qui relève ou témoigne
de bonne foi d'un crime ou d'un délit de
manquements graves à la loi ou règlement
ou de faits présentant des risques
graves pour l'environnement la santé ou
la sécurité publique
les députés précisent qu'il exerce son
droit d' alerte sans espoir davantage
propre ni volonté de nuire à autrui
il y a aussi une protection pour les
lanceurs d'alert même s'il divulguer des
informations couvertes par le secret
professionnel le lanceur dallaire ce ne
pourra pas être poursuivis devant les
tribunaux
son anonymat sera garanti ainsi que
celui des personnes mises en cause
l'état devra le protéger face aux
éventuelles représailles dans son milieu
professionnel
l'état pourra avancer ou rembourser ses
frais de justice
et peut-être même l'indemniser les
modalités exactes de ces aides
financières ne sont pas encore claires
ce sera l'objet du débat en séance
enfin il y à un protecteur le défenseur
des droits c'est lui et ses 400 délégués
sur le territoire français qui devront
aider les lanceurs d'alert si le salarié
qui dénonce des scandales n'est pas
entendue au sein de l'entreprise
il pourra faire appel à eux patrick le
riz est réglée lors sur dallas est un
sujet très présents aussi bien au niveau
français qu'européen
est ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
chose de confier la protection des
lanceurs d'alert à l'état aux défenseurs
de
petite remarque préalable c'est que la
discussion sur la loi sapin elles
montrent qu'on peut faire autrement
elles montrent que le parlement peut
avoir le pouvoir puisqu'il a plu
il a pu travailler tranquillement amendé
et améliorer le texte
à la différence de la loi de
précarisation dispose donc oui il ya là
c'est une c'est quelque chose c'est
isaac une bosse maintenant maintenant
sur le contenu oui à 100 mais plus la
gauche que connaît le travail c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai mais nous sommes la
gauche et donc il ya une majorité de
gens qui ont élu un président qui est
issu de la gauche et ça c'est le vin
doublement ici de la gauche qui ce
qu'est ce que font les défis actuels du
point de vue de la méthode c'est mieux
deuxièmement dans le contenu sur les
deux premiers versant que vous avez
énuméré ses biens les lanceurs d'alert
la loi elle va bien plus loin que la
directive européenne et elle peut être
par rapport à la directive européenne si
la directive européenne n'a pas le
primat sur notre droit français elles
seront moins seront mieux protégés et
donc ça c'est positif
les députés en revanche un ont rendu
contraignants le vote des actionnaires
sur la rémunération des patrons mais
n'ont pas voté l'encadrement de ces
rémunérations vous le regrettez oui le
bois je pense que ce qui était proposé
initialement était un premier pas
moi évidemment je suis pour un
écrasement beaucoup plus important de 1
à 20 je suis même pour de 1 à 4 de 1,6
même si vous voulez fola de le plus
petit salaire de l'entreprise
l'écart entre le plus petit salaire le
plus d le plus grande honte dans
l'entreprise je suis plutôt pour ça
parce que il est urgent de revenir à de
la justice dans notre pays
le l'ingénieur celui qui découvre une
molécule celui qui est dans laboratoire
comme l'ouvrier qui est qui est produit
il a autant de valeur que celui qui gère
et et dirigeants d'entreprises alors en
réaction à la sphère cahuzac bercy et
créons février 2014 le parquet national
financier un parquet qui traite
aujourd'hui
deux dossiers emblématiques comme les
panama peppers la corruption à la fifa
ou encore la fraude fiscale de google
mais il dispose pour cela de moyens
limités des sénateurs se sont rendus sur
place mardi
marie vraiment les a suivis 15
magistrats pour 358 affaire tentaculaire
une équation quasi impossible à résoudre
selon la procureur en chef du parquet
national financier nous sommes saisis de
tous les dossiers de fraude fiscale a
gravé à dimension internationale qui
comporte des éléments d'extranéité c'est
à dire dont les schémas sont complexes
avec le recours à des sociétés off-shore
traquer les millions d'euros à travers
le monde analyse elie milliers de
données informatiques le parquet
financier français apparaît dès lors
sous dimensionné à titre de comparaison
l'équivalent de cette institution au
royaume uni le serious fraud office
dispose de 480 personnes comprenant des
enquêteurs des juristes et des experts
une situation à laquelle s'intéresse de
très près la commission des finances du
sénat qui s'est rendu dans les locaux
parisiens du parquet financier
c'est un soutien de la commission des
finances du sénat
parce qu'elle s'intéresse à la question
à la fraude fiscale pour une raison
toute simple nous nous avons espèce de
mission qui est de veiller à l'équilibré
des finances publiques
donc nous voulons trouver de l'argent
les enjeux ici sont multiples judiciaire
technologique mais également éminemment
politique le gouvernement depuis la
sphère cahuzac a fait de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale son cheval de bataille
une bataille qui pourrait s'avérer des
plus rentables
patrick huard et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
renforcer les moyens de ce parc national
financé
oui il faut renforcer tous les moyens
qu'on peut aujourd'hui active et même ce
qu'on peut créer pour faire cesser cette
évasion et cette fraude fiscale il y a
il y a quelque chose d'insupportable
entre continuer à demander des
sacrifices à ceux qui ont très peu pour
vivre alors que d'autres qui ont
beaucoup d'argent se permettent de ne
plus participer au bien commun en
mettant leur argent aux frais ou au
chaud ce débat concernant la sphère
panama paper ces révélations à l'argent
alors j'essaie laisse que les choses
peuvent avancer aussi au niveau européen
oui le parlement européen votée hier une
délibération pour qu on crée une
commission d' enquête est donc
vraisemblable
nous allons la mettre en place nous
allons décider des noms à la prochaine
session parlementaire c'est-à-dire le 4
juillet cette semaine la société
générale a été condamnée par les
prud'hommes a payé plus de quatre cent
cinquante mille euros à son ancien
trader jérôme kerviel pour l'avoir
licencié sans causes réelles ni
sérieuses et dans des conditions
vexatoires vous saluer cette décision
bonnel tribunal des prud'hommes et
jugent comme on dit il et il est libre
c'est un fait que ça 2 c'est une
injustice incroyable qui est fait
aujourd'hui à jérôme kerviel on
il faut maintenant créer les conditions
que les poursuites contre lui
c'est ce certes vale sa défense on
prenait sa défense plutôt parce que je
ne prends pas la défense du système du
trading
parce que je suis va pour un autre
système mais dès lors qu'il est salarié
de ceux de ce système et qu'on lui a
demandé de faire de l'argent avec de
l'argent
la responsabilité première bon c'est
celle de l'employeur vraisemblablement
mais peut-être plus généralement c'est
celle d'un système qui permet de ça
c'est à dire on fabrique de l'argent
sans production et c'est ça qui est le
plus condamnable
je crois que c'est ce procès l'a en tout
cas ce débat là qu'on devrait avoir
aujourd'hui
alors on passe à mercredi où la sécurité
de l'euro de football qui a commencé est
en question les fans de nos talents
suscite toutes les craintes
bernard cazenave était de là devant la
représentation nationale aux côtés
d'alain juppé en qualité de président de
l'association des villes hôtes de l'euro
il était devant la commission des lois
ils l'ont redit tout est fait pour
garantir une sécurité maximale de
l'événement évidemment le risque zéro
n'existe pas écoutez nous sommes
convaincus qu'il est très important que
l'euro 2016 ait lieu car personne ne
soit empêché les français de vivre
normalement cédée sur l'euro eut été
cédée à l'odieux chantage des
terroristes et cela il n'en est pas
question la france doit demeurer la
france et c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'euro se tiendra nous pensons
collectivement tout cas les mères que la
fan zone est sans doute la meilleure
solution pour contrôler au mieux
l'opération ne pas dire le contraire de
ce qu à des mises à l'intérieur il n'y a
pas de risque zéro donc sommes bien
conscients des responsabilités que nous
prenons mais nous assumerons 90 mille
policiers et gendarmes mobilisés
réservistes rappelés en même temps il
n'y a pas de risque zéro vient d
annoncer qu est ce que le gouvernement
pour vous a mis le paquet pour garantir
une sécurité maximale est ce que c'est
suffisant oui je pense que je pense
qu'il a fait des efforts considérables
pour sécuriser cette grande
manifestation qui va être regarder d'un
peu partout maintenant sur le sujet
précis des fans zone peut-être qu'on
aurait pu trouver d'autres méthodes
donner plus de responsabilités aux clubs
sportifs aux associations locales
au lieu que ce soit les grands marchands
du temple active viennent vendre leurs
produits dans les fan zone c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont été maintenus pour des
raisons économiques je ne saurais pas
dire mais plus que vous posez la
question ça me fait réfléchir
c'est vous qui l'avez le gouvernement
prend t'il du coup un risque en avant en
ayant décidé de maintenir coûte que
coûte ses fans zone c qui prend un
risque de toute façon il ya un risque il
ya
il y a toujours des risques n'importe
quel rassemblement aujourd'hui il ya des
risques mais d'un autre côté il faut
bien créer les conditions pour que les
gens et puis ça a assisté deux ensembles
à des matchs communier ensemble aux
victoires françaises je l'espère tout
être d'autres et c'est pas mal que les
gens puissent se rassembler discuter
faire la fête ensemble
alors mercredi au sénat c'est patrick
drahi ce qui était auditionné par la
commission des affaires économiques le
patron de sfr numericable qui a la
parole rare a répondu avec un sens de la
formule particulier aux questions des
sénateurs julie lymphe patrick drahi à
la tête d'altis 55000 personnes 60
millions de clients à travers le monde
discret mais fier de ses choix et de sa
réussite
un patron qui a choisi de vivre en
suisse et qui assume c'est parce que
c'est très compliqué de faire du
business en france
c'est ça la réalité tout à l'heure vous
disiez c'est super tu as créé son
entreprise et de cette armée je peux
vous dire le parcours du combattant pour
créer une sarl au capital de 50 mille
francs
quand on est monsieur personnes
l'entrepreneur c'est le gars qui avaient
avancé vite pas lentement
donc c'est pour ça que mes sociétés de
tête sont à l'étranger
interpellé sur les impôts le
milliardaire réagi oui sfr payer tous
ses impôts en france
quant à l'optimisation fiscale pour
quelqu'un qui habite en france qu'un
compte en suisse non déclarés c'est de
la fraude fiscale quelqu'un qui habite
n'importe où dans le monde et qui sur la
base des lois fiscales du pays
optimiser sa fiscalité c'est quelqu'un
de malade mais je pense pas qu'il y ait
quelqu'un dans la salle qui quand il
rempli sa déclaration d'impôts et c'est
de payer plus que ce qu'il a à payer je
crois pas peut-être s'il veut souscrire
au fan club patrick drahi qui a affirmé
ce matin ne pas avoir l'intention de
jouer un rôle actif pour réactiver une
consolidation des télécoms en france
alors patrick le hyaric 1 vous avez
entendu que quelques extraits de cette
audition de patrick day que pensez vous
de sa personnalité
d'abord on n'est pas obligé de vivre à
genève pour être un grand capitaine
d'industrie nous avons de grands
capitaines d'industrie en france qui ont
réussi qui ont participé au
développement du pays à la création
d'emplois sans habiter genève et sans
cacher leur argent à droite ou à gauche
arrive la diac c'était compliqué
d'investir en france quand ont débuté
avec cinquante mille francs
comme c'était son cas est ce que c'est
compliqué dans les tirs en france au
début non moi je deux sas et c'est une
fable ça le il y a des gens qui
aujourd'hui encore investissent dans
notre pays et qui réussissent qui ont
qui ont dès qu'ils ont des succès qui
même dégage des profits qui pourrait
répartir peut-être mieux mais ça ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas vrai qu'on
ne peut pas réussir
patrick drahi un met en place un nouveau
modèle économique de regroupement des
médias et des télécoms vous qui êtes
directeur de l'humanité est ce que selon
vous c'est par là que passe l'avenir de
la presse
ah j'ai un gros problème avec ça parce
que lui maintenant il
il vient de faire une manipulation de
son capital avec son sa holding al film
altises médias qui détenait 20 journaux
il vient de tout passer sous la coupole
de sfr si on veut et il compte avec ça
offrir ce bouquet de presse avec
l'abonnement téléphonique
mais ça va poser beaucoup de questions
parce que demain notre métier de
journaliste il sera donc jugé à partir
du buzz que nous allons faire et donc on
va aller on ne fera plus des émissions
citoyenne comme vous êtes en train de le
faire on va dire ça se voit pas assez
donc il faut un autre modèle il faut
écrire autrement il faut que on
uniformise encore plus d'informations
qu'on la baisse vers le bas deuxièmement
il
il a un modèle économique donc qui va
utiliser le travail la création
l'intelligence des journalistes et le
traitement de l'information pour les
mettre dans ces dans ces canaux de
téléphonique
et voilà que maintenant il veut sur une
partie de l'abonnement téléphonique
qu'il va considérer comme un abonnement
aux journaux il veut bénéficier d'un
taux de tva à 2,1 pour cent vous savez
il n'ya pas besoin d'habiter à genève
pour faire ce détournement de tva qui
part et elle va lui rapporter 350
millions d'euros supplémentaires
est-ce que selon vous il ya un risque
pour l'indépendance de la presse ben oui
il y a déjà un risque sérieux pour pour
l'indépendance de là
si il ne suffit pas d'avoir un
pluralisme de titres si on ne crée pas
les conditions pour aider des rédactions
indépendante qui traite à partir de
leurs options éditorial évidemment à
partir de leurs opinions
ça s'est il faut lé il faut le respecter
jusqu'au bout si on ne respecte pas ça
on aura une uniformisation et des
journalistes qui seront peu ou prou
moins indépendants - libres de faire ce
qu'ils veulent alors patrick le hyaric
qu'on va avancer on va retourner à
l'actualité politique puisque manuel
valls a tenu meeting avec la volonté de
resserrer les rangs de la majorité
meeting intitulé loi travail face aux
régressions de la droite sénatoriale
défendons le progrès social
quentin calmet étaient sur place
objectif ce soir défendre coûte que
coûte la loi travail et remobiliser les
socialistes pris par le doute
manuel valls myriam el khomri stéphane
le foll tous le martèle le gouvernement
ne reculera pas
la démocratie ce n'est pas la rue la
démocratie c'est le vote
la démocratie c'est la démocratie
sociale dans l'entreprise
chacun peut dire tombons dans quelques
jours la loi sera examiné par le sénat à
majorité de droite
l'occasion de ce meeting c'est donc
aussi de marquer sa différence avec les
républicains le problème de la france
c'est la droite
un sénateur de droite avait d'ailleurs
fait le déplacement
jean-baptiste lemoyne et même rapporteur
de la loi elle conneries ils dénoncent
la supercherie de ce meeting
je trouve ça un peu facile d'essayer de
refaire une unité qui n'existe plus haut
niveau du parti socialiste sur le dos de
la droite un rendez vous qui s'est tenue
dans une grande tension tout un quartier
de paris bloqué des manifestants aux
abords de la salle le signe que la
nervosité autour de la loi travail n'est
toujours pas retombée
on a donc vu que le co rapporteur du
projet de loi pour la droite sénatoriale
jean-baptiste lemoyne s'est déplacé chez
les socialistes pour montrer le
retournement de la majorité patrick le
hyaric manuel go my way valse de
rassembler la gauche est ce que c'est
lui le mieux placé faire cela
aujourd'hui pour rassembler la gauche
non puisque d'abord il la met un petit
peu en miettes et d'autre part c'est lui
même qui a prononcé cette phrase assez
terrible à laquelle je ne crois pas du
tout il a dit il y a deux gauches
irréconciliables donc il n'est pas en
train de la rassembler il est en train
de la diviser
puis peut-être pour l'effacer du paysage
qui peut rassembler la gauche
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs
personnalités qui pourrait rassembler la
gauche de transformation sociale et
écologique moi je n'ai pas de nom précis
mais il y a plusieurs personnalités
aujourd'hui dans la gauche qui peuvent
le faire hier emmanuel macron a attribué
les difficultés du gouvernement à faire
adopter la loi travail au débat sur la
déchéance de la nationalité en début
d'année qui dit il a brisé beaucoup de
gens à gauche est ce que vous êtes
d'accord eux c'était une erreur d'avoir
lancé cette affaire au mois de décembre
pour une multitude de raisons c'est que
le président de la république reprenait
quand même une proposition de droite
voire de droite extrême
si ce n'était pas d'extrême droite et
donc ça posait aux problèmes
deuxièmement ça c'est sûr ces cendres là
quand il a arrêté qu'on a lancé par la
suite le débat sur la loi de précarité
du travail
mais le fonds n'est pas que cela le fond
de l'air c'est que il y à un reniement
des engagements qui ont été pris et dès
lors qu'il ya eu ce reniement et dès
lors que par exemple cette loi de
précarisation de travail non n'a jamais
été dans le programme ni du parti
socialiste puisque le parti socialiste a
voté à dans ses textes est exactement le
contraire de l'article depuis ce qu'il
dit dans ses textes qu'il est pour la
loi et non pas pour le contrat donc
cette c'est un renversement qu'il
procède à la tête de l'état ajouté au
fait qu'on
ne règle pas les grands enjeux du
chômage on n'a pas fait de d'avancé par
exemple sur le smic depuis le début du
quinquennat
tous ces mécontentements qui c'est qui
ce qui s'agglomèrent aujourd'hui sont
tellement bouillie que c'est en train
d'exploser c'est à dire que c'est une
multitude de facteurs peut-être la loi
deschamps a su arrêter mais la question
sociale
elle devient première dans ce pays et
moi ça me réjouit plutôt c'est un débat
aujourd'hui plus intéressant mais même
si sa ged des gens même si ça crée des
inconvénients que le débat souvenez vous
que nous avions à l'automne
on va finir justement la semaine avec le
sénat qui se prépare à l'examiner cette
fois travail la majorité sénatoriale de
droite qui a réécrit le projet doit
travail
revenons plutôt à la première version du
texte présenté par manuel valls voir en
allant encore plus loin dans les mesures
libérales juni l'un dans un climat de
fronde sociale qui se prolonge pour la
loi travail
l'heure est à la séance publique au
sénat où seront étudiées pas moins de
900 amendements et deux motions
communiste sur la table le texte amendé
par la majorité sénatoriale de droite
plus souple selon eux plus libérale pour
d'autres c'est un texte où il ya
effectivement plus de souplesse d'un
certain nombre de domaines pour les
entreprises notamment les pme quitter
les grandes oubliées du texte mais en
même temps également où on met plus de
retour aux salariés la commission
chargée de relire le texte a supprimé 12
articles finis la généralisation de la
garantie jeunes qui permet le versement
d'une allocation de 461 euros par mois
fini également la référence aux 35
heures le nombre d'heures travaillées
sera décidée par un accord d'entreprise
en revanche le sénat a conservé le
principe de la hiérarchie des normes et
réintroduit la mesure de plafonnement
des indemnités de licenciement aux
prud'hommes un retour en arrière selon
la gauche qui souhaitent profiter des
débats pour clarifier ses intentions
le sénat va
être l'occasion de poursuivre ce débat
non pas entre nous mais avec les
français et donc mon travail comme ceux
de mes collègues du groupe socialiste
c'est de faire la pédagogie de la
réforme c'est pas de polémique s est de
débattre faire de la pédagogie pour
apaiser les tensions et patienter car si
manuel valls s'est dit ouvert aux
propositions du sénat
c'est sans aucun doute le 49-3 qui aura
le dernier mot à l'assemblée nationale
la série quand vous lisez le texte du
sénat qu'est ce que vous dites que
finalement le projet de l'allemagne elle
va ce n'est pas si mal c'est moins
mauvais que si c'était pire c'est simple
vous voulez me faire dire non le il
était évident que le sénat allait
revenir aux dispositions les plus
négatives voire aggraver
mais ce n'est pas parce que on a ces
modifications très régressive que la loi
telle qu'elle a été adoptée par le 49-3
est acceptable
ils ne font peut pas jouer on ne peut
pas jouer avec ça vous pensé justement
que le gouvernement va une nouvelle fois
passer en force en utilisant l'article
49 3 en deuxième lecture en moi je
souhaite pas moi je souhaite que l'on
fasse une pause que ya une discussion
qu'on regarde les problèmes qui sont en
suspens et qu'on revienne mais j'ai une
proposition très simple le président de
la république quand il était candidat
avait repris une proposition de la cgt
qui est celle de la sécurisation des
parcours professionnels et bien qu'on
reparte de ça et que la coquille vide du
compte personnel d'activité
aujourd'hui on l'alimentent à partir de
ce vote de ce projet là qui était qui
est une avancée considérable dans le
moment que nous connaissons l'aide la
discussion elle s'engage la entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats
myriam el khomri rencontrera vendredi
prochain philippe martin elle vient tu
regardes la cgt c'est une bonne chose
très bien est-ce que selon vous on va
vers une réécriture de l'article 2 par
exemple
bâle le il y aura et durera sans doute
des modifications qui devraient
permettre de tenir compte du fait que on
ne peut pas avoir une loi par entreprise
la tradition française et la tradition
de la gauche française
c'est la loi qui protège le faible et
dès lors que la loi protège le faible
c'est une loi pour tous le monde sony
n'y a pas une loi en lozère une autre
ancienne saint denis et une autre à
lille
est-ce que vous pensez que cette loi
peut être à adopter et appliquer en
pleine année présidentielle
or vous savez entre le vote d'une loi et
puis les décrets d'application vous
savez hiriart il y a toujours du temps
qu'il se passe et donc c'est pour s'en
verrait les choses à la saint glinglin
peut-être non mais peut-être que c'est
bien si la gauche de transformation
sociale et écologique avait un candidat
élu nous ferions une très bonne loi
qu'on pourrait appeler travail cette
fois là alors on va parler d'europe avec
la question à la une les britanniques
vont ils ou non choisir de quitter
l'union européenne questions inédites et
l'incertitude qui domine
jusqu'au 23 juin avec le référendum
david cameron et l'eurosceptique nigel
farage ont débattu cette semaine sur la
chaîne britannique
eyetv débats retransmis en direct sur
notre antenne que vous avez pu suivre
alors patrick le hyaric êtes vous plutôt
qu'à mono farage hendrix il peut-être
peut-il être salutaire pour l'europe
je regardais l'autre soit ce débat sur
votre chaîne très décevant très très peu
très petit non ce que je constate c'est
que on a donnés à monsieur cameron ce
qu'on a refusé cet été à monsieur de six
places deuxièmement pour que monsieur
cameron puisse faire ce référendum est
qu'ils puissent le gagner on lui a fait
de nouvelles exemptions donc je ne suis
ni l'un ni l'autre je suis pour une
transformation progressiste extrêmement
profond ce de la construction européenne
et si les britanniques sorte demain
devient européenne vous pensez que c'est
le big bang en europe non je ne crois
pas je ne ne crois que ça va ouvrir un
débat de fond
ça veut dire aussi qu'il nous faudra
pour vous comment ça peut être une bonne
chose dont je ne crois pas je ne crois
pas que ce soit une bonne chose moi je
ne suis pas pour la stratégie de la
terre brûlée
je suis pour écouter les syndicats sept
syndicats ben
au royaume uni le parti travailliste
dans notre ami monsieur corps been
les écossais le pays de galles les
irlandais qui sont contre la sortie
parce qu'ils savent ce qu'ils vont
perdre mais par contre ce n'est pas soit
la thèse de cameron soit le statu quo
l'enjeu fondamental c'est comment qu'on
peut transformer et qu'on va vers une
europe plus démocratique à une europe
qui va en fait en enfin vers un dessin
sociale patrick le hyaric le jean jaurès
et nous a rejoint sur ce plateau seller
tout de suite de la loupe du scan
bonjour patrick le hyaric vous avez deux
députés européens mais aussi directeur
de l'humanité on l'a dit votre journal a
été le seul quotidien national à
paraître le 26 mai dernier puisqu'il a
été le seul à accepter la parution d'un
communiqué dans le tract de la cgt
contre la loi travail le syndicat a
bloqué l'impression d autres journaux
est ce que vous pensez que cette méthode
est correct est ce que c'est une bonne
méthode
mais pas plus que pour les syndicats des
travailleurs du livre pas plus que ceux
des éboueurs ou de la sncf
moi je n'ai pas à prendre partie je n'ai
à prendre position sur les méthodes
d'action
quant à cantat quand je suis pas patron
je suis directeur du journal
comme vous avez vous-même impropre
direct de clameur qui fait pas non plus
patron je l'appelle papa trentaine de
collègues et donc ils choisissent leur
leurs méthodes
quant à la publication du texte de
philippe martinez il y avait pas de
raison que nous ne publions pas ce texte
puisque philippe martinez il est
régulièrement interviewé dans le journal
il a les délégués cgt et d'autres
syndicalistes ont des tribunes dans le
journal donc nous n'avions pas raison de
lui refuser vous est aussi président de
l'association pour le pluralisme de la
presse je crois est-ce que s'il n'ya pas
justement une rupture de ce principe de
pluralisme
quand il n'y a qu'un seul quotidien qui
paraît avec les autres sont bloqués ah
si il ya une rupture de pluralisme ce
n'est pas une bonne chose qu'il n'y ait
qu'un seul journal dans les kiosques
moi je souhaite non pas dix journaux ou
en journaux nationaux dans les coins
dans lakers mais gens souhaiteraient 40
plus voilà vous avez dit tout à l'heure
en début d'émission que le rassemblement
du front de gauche si on peut encore
l'appeler comme ça était et est toujours
possible
ça passe par quoi ça passe peut-être par
le soutien des communistes à la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon c'est
envisageable ça ça passe par le travail
qui est engagée ce que j'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure c'est à dire le parti
communiste a décidé de faire une grande
consultation auprès de 500 ou 600 mille
personnes sur ce à quoi aspirent les
gens nous en avons bien une idée mais
nous voulons avoir ce débat avec eux
mais ça programmatique pas que
programmatique c'est à dire il peut il
peut y avoir
l'élection à la présidence de la
république moi je pense que un candidat
à la présidence de la république doit
avoir un dessin pour la france mais pas
pour cinq ans plus tôt pour 50 ans la
question des élections législatives
après c'est un programme de législature
et donc il faut avoir une vision
d'avenir du pays et tirer le pays vers
la et le le parti communiste compte fin
du mois de septembre
proposer ce qu'il appelle un pacte
d'engagement commun à partir de cette
consultation la et qui va converger
puisque c'est votre question qui
convergera vraisemblablement avec un
certain nombre de choses que propose
jean luc mélenchon lui-même vous fermez
absolument pas la porte à un
rapprochement en vue de la
présidentielle
avec avec jean luc mélenchon ce nous le
débat aujourd'hui et le débat kkk lancé
pierre laurent depuis plusieurs mois il
est il est un débat qui porte sur la
question deux pour un candidat de la
transformation sociale de gagner
l'élection présidentielle et de gagner
les élections législatives d'avoir une
autre majorité au parlement
c'est ça le débat est donc tout son
effort et consiste à rechercher les
conditions d'une telle candidature
mais cette candidature peut être jean
luc mélenchon si toutes ces forces qui
aujourd'hui se réclame de dinde un
changement véritable se réclame vraiment
du côté gauche
et bien si tout d'efforts se retrouve
dans la candidature de jean-luc
mélenchon elle a peut être jean luc
mélenchon il refuse il l'a déjà dit
plusieurs fois le principe de la
primaire à gauche que le pcf lui
soutient ou soutenait en tout cas est ce
que vous pensez qu'il ya de primaire
elle a encore ses chances
non le pari leur parti communiste
contrairement à ses traditions et son
histoire début janvier quand s'est posé
la question de la primaire le jour même
le soir même lors de ses voeux pierre
laurent a dit que ce n'était pas sa
culture mais qu'il ouvrait la porte
les choses ont beaucoup changé depuis
aujourd'hui le il a il a avancé l'idée
de créer les conditions peut-être d'une
consultation d'une sorte de votation
citoyenne au mois d'octobre
mais la primaire telle qu'elle était
conçue initialement ne peut pas avoir
lieu
on ne peut pas faire une primaire
aujourd'hui avec des des gens qui font
par exemple la loi de précarisation du
travail
je voulais vous faire réagir à une
petite phrase prononcée par jean
christophe cambadélis l'est c'est la
semaine dernière lors d'une fête de la
rose dans l'yonne il a dit je regarde
que le pca ferme à nouveau la porte de
l'unité et ce qui est encore quelque
chose à tirer de la relation entre le
pcf et le parti socialiste aujourd'hui
mais bien sûr ce sont deux
courant d'une d'une vieille même branche
seulement le problème il porte sur la
question de savoir si on peut changer la
société
vraisemblablement la direction du parti
socialiste je parle du parti socialiste
je ne parle pas du gouvernement à la
direction du parti socialiste
vraisemblement depuis plusieurs années
on pense qu'il faut s'aligner sur le
parti socialiste européen et on
considère que dans le cadre de la
mondialisation actuelle vaut mieux
s'adapter
nous nous pensons que dans le cadre de
la mondialisation vaut mieux créer les
conditions d'une transformation sociale
et écologique
sinon nous irons dans le mur nous irons
dans le mur d'un point de vue économique
et social et surtout sur la question
écologique 40 secondes pas uniquement
sur cette question l'union de la gauche
en 2012 vous étiez désisté au second
tour des législatives en
seine-saint-denis au profit d'elisabeth
guigou qui était mieux placé que vous au
second tour seriez vous prêt à faire la
même chose en 2017 si jamais la
situation se présentait je ne sais pas
quelles sont vos ambitions mais si
jamais
seriez vous prêt à vous désister non je
resterai oui parce que la situation est
totalement différente
d'abord je constate que dans une
élection départementale partiel à
allonnes le mans mes amis sont en tête
nous avons fait un ticket écologistes et
mon ami le maire d'allonnes les
candidats socialistes à de droite ni
d'extrême droite au second tour c'est à
aubervilliers il n'y en avait pas non
plus à aubervilliers il y en avait pas
non plus mais aujourd'hui dans les
conditions d'aujourd'hui
vu ce que madame la députée vote au
parlement
je n'ai pas de points d'accord et je
resterai vraisemblable c'est merci
beaucoup merci dit merci patrick le
hyaric d'avoir refait la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec nous et
merci à vous de votre fidélité et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine sur lcp
public sénat bye bye